soon to be supreme court justice katanji
brown jackson has said she stands on the
shoulders of another trail-blazing black
woman that's constant baker motley 60
years ago motley argued a historic case
involving james meredith who was the
first black student at the racially
segregate segregated university of
mississippi erika duncan caught up with
meredith and a washington girl who
already sees her own place on the high
court tarika good morning to you what
are they thinking at this very historic
moment yeah you can only imagine as
we've seen a lot of people excited about
this there's clearly no shortage of
people who have expressed what this
confirmation means to them so we wanted
to get a unique perspective not only
from a young person but from someone who
has seen a lot of firsts and knows the
power in pursuing a dream no matter how
long it takes
[Applause]
for the many who cheered for
confirmation they finally got their
justice
for 88-year-old james meredith of
mississippi constant baker motley comes
to mind when he thinks about the next
supreme court justice she
is
almost like a judge motley said she's
not as tall but she seems to be as smart
i share a birthday
with the first black woman ever to be
appointed as a federal judge
the honorable constance baker motley as
an attorney for the naacp legal defense
fund she was the first african-american
woman to argue before the supreme court
ultimately winning nine of her ten cases
including an historic victory that
involved james meredith back in 1962.
the crowd had come to see him turned
away
the supreme court ruled meredith had a
right to attend the university of
mississippi making him the first black
student to do so meredith says
thursday's confirmation and the
fulfillment of the president's promise
was decades in the making the black
woman has always been the one that's
been
left out
we have a woman vice president we have a
woman ambassador to the u.n but i still
think
in american reality
the supreme court justice
is the biggest
thing not just for a woman but for
anybody and particularly for a young
woman even as young as madison morgan
dear president biden hello i'm an 11
year old girl from washington d.c in
february she penned a letter to
president biden saying in part i had
heard that you wanted to appoint a black
woman and well that's me but like any
good justice morgan knew the
constitution doesn't require a minimum
age or even a law degree to serve on the
supreme court it started in like fourth
grade where i saw that there weren't
many requirements to be a supreme court
justice so i just thought well i shoot
my shot while morgan didn't make the cut
she did make it to the first day of the
hearings what was that like to be
invited it was absolutely crazy it made
me feel like i was honorable and
important it's hard for me not to look
at you and not see my mom
i see my ancestors and yours
when you look at
her what do you see i see a woman with
passion and a dream
a dream that james meredith says he
envisioned when he dared to challenge a
system because it was never just about
him
it was about justice for all
they the young black women are the
future
my great hope
is that every black woman will be
inspired
by miss brown jackson
to the extent that they
will take the touch and run with it
wow he had so much more to say it was an
honor to speak with both meredith mr
meredith and madison as well both had
such different takes no doubt inspired
by what they saw yesterday of course uh
watching the hearings and also some
people that were inspired my grandmother
and my aunts were able to attend
the first hearing there they are right
there wow i know doris mcquaid duncan's
gonna flip out when she sees the picture
on tv which one is she she's right there
at the bottom sitting with the shades on
her hat there she is very nice
as well listen we have not heard the
last of madison morgan either and i love
hearing what mr meredith has to say
about what this means i mean you can't
help but look at it and think i'm so
sorry it took this long yeah when you
look at the course of history it's
really sorry that it took this long but
so glad that it has finally happened
yeah and people have pointed out she's
unlikely to change the ideological shift
of the court but for the first time in
the 230 year history of the supreme
court the majority will not be white men
yeah you've got to start somewhere and
one got to start one image comes to mind
you remember the committee testimony
where her daughter seventeen-year-old
daughter laila was looking at her mother
that's the way she's beaming with pride
it seems like collectively as a country
we are all beaming with that same
project a good analogy i love that
picture
absolutely all right thank you very much